jacob zuma
oh have you heard of this guy this is
face ring a bell
what if i say his name is jacob get lai
e
le kisa zuma now do you understand well
this man
is the former president of south africa
and here you can find him
breaking it down
[Applause]
a quirky figure you might say well zuma
has all kinds of
history history that involves accepting
bribes
corruption fraud racketeering
you know ah just just one of those
it doesn't matter if there's one thing
for cern about jacob zuma
and that's one thing numbers is jacob
zuma's
number one enemy okay let's watch one of
my favorite clips of jacob zuma
one of many we announced that
our membership figures stood
at 769
700 listen properly
i am i'm 169
000 820.
thank you you know without the 70 in the
end i would really have thought he
didn't know what
the hell he was talking about let's see
if we can follow that let's just see if
we can
why should i use the tech stock stored
at
769 767
800 and you mean 669 million
eight hundred seven hundred i am seven
hundred
seven sixty nine and sixty nine seven
eight
hundred ten twenty eight 820
oh i see okay so he started he started
over here
it still doesn't match and seven
and 70 members down from
100 100 ah come on
cut him some slack all right why should
he know how to handle numbers it's not
like he's the president
oh my god you think america was dealt a
bad hand okay
think of south africa but he's so funny
and quirky he does dancing
but wait there is more oh god there's so
many more
[Music]
this guy just keeps grabbing numbers
from everywhere whatever you think he's
done he just adds another thousand
another million it doesn't matter come
on you know it's not like a
five-year-old could do this better
876 quintillion
946 quadrillion
351 trillion 798 billion
345 million six hundred one thousand
and one
this is the greatest kid in the world
769 800
and 700
listen properly this is the greatest key
the number of babies
born the number of babies hiv positive
was reduced
by 66 percent from 24 000
in 2008 to 8.
the numbers jacob what do they mean
eight point two two eight point two
hundred the numbers dropped from twenty
four thousand
to eight point two two eight point two
hundred if anyone knows what that means
let me know i really like these uh news
clips because they have a translator and
they just don't know
how to translate his ineptitude
look at this
[Applause]
this guy is talking about nuclear
numbers
you know it's no coincidence that the
doomsday clock is
what how how close is it it's two
minutes ah that's fine
doesn't matter maybe just maybe we need
to be more careful
with who we vote for in our democracies
9 939 million
360 thousand
wow where did he get that numbers
jobs grew by 200
and 3 000
that's a great statistics they grew by
two hundred
and three thousand apples
i think if i i don't have the figure it
could be it doesn't have the figure
um between seven to eight hundred this
continent
is the best continent
in the world not separated even by
a river the rivers that are there flow
with the continent they don't cut it
how can you have
all continents put together will fit in
into africa
oh wow fun fact
fun fact time all continents fit into
africa
you know he's not wrong he's not just
the master of numbers he's also master
of the fun facts
all continents fit into africa as you
can tell here
this is one of those illusions where it
looks like it wouldn't work
but if you try it you can see it
clearly like usa has so much space
north america has so much space left
in africa and if you take europe
there's plenty of space from europe as
well
uh if you cut it out it yes you can tell
here it all
fits in the africa all right this guy is
a president
of a country jesus christ
how are we alive how one billion
he is literally the scene from
washington powers one
billion dollar it's literally the living
embodiment
i don't know what a billion is in zulu
is that true is that the actual
translation that can't be right
but it's money that can't run away that
can't run away
billions has been stolen from
governments okay this is very concerning
government has remarkably grown
the program from supporting
300 000 children
now apparently zuma has had such an
impact
that other people are affected by this
there's a conspiracy going on
called the zuma virus that makes people
not
able to number look at the translator
here
but what did we allocate 88 million but
we expected
but my favorite one is this one i don't
know if this is even real
problematic proper memorizing
problematic purple
[Music]
you can tell how done the translator
lady is she's oh she leaves advertising
all professionals
[Laughter]
i'll give you one thing though he has a
contagious laugh
and i think he knows thank you very much
if i can laugh because i will always
laugh
answer i'm going to
mr president it appears that you are
very well advised by your minister of
health because medical experts say
that if you want to live a long and
healthy life then you laugh every day
so i think that's for you
that is the fakest life i have ever
heard
you know some people
who could not pronounce ganja they have
now learned
is this guy actually roasting people how
they can articulate
jesus christ
i really miss him he used to steal so
much money from our taxpayers
he's one of the clever ones he might be
stupid but he still managed to take a
lot of essay money
jesus christ dude apparently god laily
casa means one who smiles while causing
you harm well isn't that ironic
julian on zima thank you for coming in
thank you good morning
here's zuma's brother who says
i'm gay you are gay
i'm not sexually active right now
so what is my choice by choice
i've just not have chosen not to engage
doesn't that make you gay
why doesn't that make me gay i am i am
male
and attracted to a female jesus christ
so who is gay
oh god i feel like i shouldn't laugh
it's just sad oh well
good morning why are you gay straight to
the point
i'm male and attracted to fear myself
oh god all right well that's all you
need to know about jacob zuma if you
enjoyed this video
smash like subscribe we gotta hit 100
million come on bros
since i still have you make sure to
check out epic merch represent dot com
slash pewdiepie support the channel
and i'll see you guys tomorrow what you
never play
too but emily you know it's
fun right i'm not supposed to give my
opinion
but give it a try and then you can tell
me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay i'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
you